- So John, if I'm a student
studying American history
or U.S. government, why should I care?
- Well first, there are great stories.
The characters in American
history, all the way through,
are fascinating, just, human beings.
They would make great
movie characters, period:
heroes, villains, people
who rise to courage
when they were otherwise
pretty boring people.
Look at Abraham Lincoln, for example.
He failed miserably repeatedly,
repeatedly, repeatedly.
Then he becomes the greatest President.
And when he's almost at the end of his,
well, he doesn't know
it's the end of his life,
but later in life, after
he's had his greatness,
he says, "I confess that I
was like a cork in a stream."
Well, if you're a regular
person and you think,
"My life feels kinda without a purpose,"
you can think, well, the
greatest President in America
felt like his life was
kind of bouncing around.
And so, that is an
incredibly human connection
to greatness, and we all need connections
to greatness of whatever
kind to inspire us.
Because the questions
today that America faces
about freedom and
liberty and what it means
to be an American, and how the power
is distributed throughout our governments
and our lives that affect us today
were discussed and talked
about and wrestled over
all throughout American history.
And it is a continuing experiment.
And when Thomas Jefferson wrote
the Declaration of Independence, he said,
"This new country that we're creating
"has to constantly refresh,
each new generation
"has to refresh their contact
"with the original ideals that
the country was founded on.
"Otherwise, the country will fail."
And so, it's not only important to know
what's going on around
us by studying history,
but it is, according to Thomas Jefferson,
your duty to stay engaged
with the ideas of America
so that those ideas don't get lost
in the kind of flurry and
craziness of a current moment.